voilà ce soir grande soirée poétique et
musicale avec fulbert anselme du snop
dans cette fois mais ça me semble bien y
avoir un monde de fous coup
ma chère amie mais que vous arrive-t-il
à écouter arrêter ses excentricités
voulait pas mal de mou
du tout avancé à rêver et à animer votre
clown pour les spectacles spéciaux par a
c'est totalement impossible ma chère
amie comprends parce que ce soir dans le
théâtre de verdure de nos enfants il ya
une grande soirée poétique et musical en
quelque sorte one man show quoi c'est
pardonnez moi j'ai la mienne je
m'aperçois que j'en prends à témoin un
peu difficile pour nous north one man
show est une expression anglaise croit
en anglais signifie à melle au show
spectacle one man show voilà en quelques
mots c'est un spectacle d'un seul homme
mais qui se rase et salom chers amis le
seul qui puisse faire une prouesse
artistique
pas c'est curieux je ne vois pas du tout
du tout qui sape et peut-être c'est
intolérable
nous voyons philbert en scène me 10,9
bien
ça alors je n'aurais jamais trouvé seul
c'est comme ça je dois me retirer
ce pauvre monsieur dix neuf mois d'août
d'arrière ce récital poétique n'aura pas
lieu
pourquoi pour la bonne et simple raison
que le spectacle de ce soir sera un
grand récital de devinettes
par casimir
voilà
non non écouter monsieur du snob ça me
gêne beaucoup ce que vous me demandez là
on sait françois je vous ne vous
laisserai pas vous dérobez d'être le
seul ici tu puisses y est arbitré d'une
façon impartiale ce conflit et ainsi me
donner raison au dessus du snob et qu'il
faudrait qu'on aime savoir ce que vous
dites vous demander d'arbitrer de façon
impartiale
cela veut dire que je juge v ce qui
s'est passé s'en prendre à l'avancé ni
votre parti ni celui de casimir je ne
peux donc pas tout de suite vous dire si
je vous donnerai réseau pas se mentir
non d'accord entièrement parfait alors
donc il s'agit de savoir qui donnera son
spectacle ce soir c'est cela même s'ils
disent 'non' le règlement de lille et
avec précision que c'est celui qui
annonce son spectacle par une affiche
qui aura la priorité nous sommes
d'accord alors dessus du snob
regardez ces casimir qui a affiché le
premier son spectacle donc c'est lui
qu'il fera françois regarder mon afrique
endroit nettement qu'elle a été arrachée
effectif mais oui mais cela ne prouve
pas que cette affiche est été arraché de
ce poteau
à jeter moins
moisselles julie et j'ai l'étude tu as
vu ce qui s'est passé à ça je reconnais
que monsieur d'islam a été le premier à
apporter sont la fiche
est bien dans ce cas je vais faire venir
casimir et ensuite je prendrai une
décision bien que du mur et pas répond
quelque chose mon vieux fans du oui ou
non racheter la fiche de monsieur du
snob pour mettre la tienne à la place
moi
je ne m'en souviens pas du tout c'est
curieux geagea par la mémoire en ce
moment vraiment le jeu cassure je ne me
souviens de rien et bien casimir nous ne
parlons plus de 5 alors casimir ton ton
récital de devinettes ce soir ce sera
bien ce sera formidable vous n'allez pas
vous ennuyer j'en connais deux sens
quand parker moteur bon tu as raison
j'exagère un peu j'en connais mettant
seulement 225 et je ne parle pas de ça
casimir je dis que tu es un menteur
parce qu'il ya deux secondes tu m'as dit
que tu avais perdu la mémoire et
maintenant tout d'un coup tu te souviens
de 2 225 vinette parker pour fo se tient
pas debout que du mur tous et ça va je
n'y avais pas pensé
casimir que s'est-il passé avec la fiche
de monsieur du snob pourrait bien par à
coups de vent l'a arraché
casimir c'est pas vrai ce matin il n'y a
pas eu un souffle d'air je t'assure à
quand j'ai tiré dessus cela a fait un
petit courant d'air
il ya casimir je suis désolé mais ce
soir c'est monsieur du snob qui donnera
son spectacle
bon eh bien tant pis tout le monde sans
nuire à avec ses poèmes 1 mais je lui
réserve une surprise à bonjour juju tout
à coiffe pour moi toi et puis pour les
autres si sûr me coiffe pour le récital
de politique de monsieur du stade ce
soir
est-ce que tu as vaillant un pot de
colle forte
toute conne
mais tu me le rendre à ange en est
vraiment juste pour une minute
merci
ne dit rien à personne et je vais mettre
de la colle forte sur la scène à
l'endroit où monsieur du snav a posé ses
pieds
voilà qui est fait
quand il dira à ses poèmes il restera
collé je crois qu'on va bien rire
voilà merci je jure
je ne vous salue pas monsieur ou moi
c'est bien dernier de mes soucis or vous
êtes ravissante chers amis je remercie
beaucoup pensaient alors monsieur vous
êtes fin prêt pour votre récital toute
neuve près
oui mais ce qui va étonner l'assistance
c'est l'extraordinaire mise en scène
avec laquelle je vais déclamer mais pour
moi c'est cher surtout avec les pieds
collés c'était moi rien rien du tour ah
bon je vais vous donner un exemple vous
pourriez licites
ou ô combien de capitaines nom
ou ô combien de marins combien de
capitaines qui sont partis joyeux vers
des cox lointaine
alors qu'on pensait bouger ses deux
jambes oui et non et honneur à ses très
très original ajoutant que le triomphe
approche allez moi quand moi monsieur je
nomme je sens que c'est l'heure de votre
récital julie tu rassembles les enfants
l'accord les enfants venez vite écoutez
monsieur du snapap valérie poret
et maintenant le récital poétique de
fulbert en scène du snuff
[Applaudissements]
au
[Rires]
jour au
combien de marins combien de capitaines
qui sont partis joyeux
mais
c'est ma collègue à servir comme moi et
alors la famille